[Music]
so after a long fun and just like great
night of bonding with these dudes
drinking kava it's like how the hood
does it like the dead homies you put it
over the gray right yeah that's awesome
cheer sells that's interesting yeah this
ain't like a room it does not taste as
bad as the powder there's powder bags
that can taste a little bit gnarly take
that to actually you just don't like the
powder taste terrible we define it I do
remember am i sleepy and inebriated
state that he said that I had a get spam
musubi from this local joint right here
now apparently back in the day 7-elevens
when they weren't so popular a lot of
those like mom-and-pop liquor stores
this fan musubi and all the general said
that everybody would get and they said
that this spam musubi is the best and
you have to get an earlier in the
morning because they make it fresh and
the spam is actually crispy on its own
I'm super hype about this my goal in
life is to look for the best man used to
be and I kind of told him that 7-eleven
was my favorite they laughed in my
[ __ ] face so so we made a mistake of
coming in here and filming without
asking permission which is completely
our fault I think we're so used to just
walking around and doing what we want
and that's my fault because that's
actually pretty disrespectful to come
into a store and you start filming so
this guy is hilarious and that he came
up to us is I don't you think it's a
little wrong for you to come up here
without asking permission which he's a
hundred percent right but the way he
went about it it's just so hilarious but
this guy's freaking awesome
so the the cool thing about a lot of
these local stores that he was telling
us is that this is kind of like a
neighborhood staple and they sell about
like 400 to 500 of these likes bamboo
soubise weekly so it's it's really one
of those things that everybody has
growing up as a kid and once again like
you look in the store and kind of
reminds me of my parents store where a
has like that neighborhood feel and you
could tell that this is the spot that
everybody goes to just to get their
random stuff and you've definitely got
to have like a Korean person now like
that and he was telling me earlier he
goes oh I spoke to the Korean I was like
are you Korean he goes to can't you tell
I'm angry I was gonna kick is an S so
this place move like the regionals is
owned by one person but like like like a
lot of the local said like there's not
many of these
oh yeah get close to Bobby yeah it is a
lot of like the neighborhood like family
it's old neighbor just like you feminine
environment
everybody notes by name so when people
come in and it a little short on change
oh yeah yeah the difference with this
Pam compared to other spam musubi is
number one they actually crisp it up so
the other ones that we see it's usually
sauced out yeah it's soggy this one is
crisp as hell mm-hmm
the rice amount is actually a lot
smaller so you kind of get like a good
amount of both I can see why a lot of
local people like 20 mm-hmm it's a
different style for fare yeah he was mad
at us but I'm not mad at you
oh if you guys want to check out the
spot and you want to try the crispy spam
musubi the place is called kama milder
market out of Honolulu a really small
neighborhood joint just remember be
respectful be mindful don't get all
crazy loud in there start Buster's [ __ ]
up just
that guy will [ __ ] kill you
okay oh my god I'm good
[Music]
poka is one of my favorite favorite
dishes and when I come to this and you
already know I got a rubdown on this
thing now usually I go to Yama's fish
market but a couple of locals told me
that this is actually the spot that you
want to go to I don't know how true this
is before they told me is that local
fishermen or people who catch fish they
come here and they bring their catch
here and actually make that fresh fish
poke a fresh ass fish
okay I really don't know what to expect
I just go to my same spots like I just
got a fool and get some poke day which
is pretty damn good in my opinion but if
this is the spot that the local people
are telling me to go to that I've got to
go here I think there's like two other
locations but we're on our way to go zip
lining up stuff up here and try to stuff
out what I like to do when I come to a
polka spot is I like to get a little bit
of everything so me and Joe decided to
get our favorites this is already Joe's
favorite right here show you yeah I'm a
bland ass [ __ ] but the best way to try
something has actually tasted so I'm
gonna have Joe try his favorite one
because I'm a connoisseur
that's actually really sweet it's a bomb
it's like candy
oh my god that's really [ __ ] good
this is something different it's sweet
it's like
to the candy to me you know I was like a
caramel flavor probably from like to
show you and there's like a sweetness to
it too that kind of just melds really
well with that saltiness so she actually
hates fish and I got her to want to try
this
he said candies well another thing
people don't know that fish is not
supposed to be fishy at all they are
fresh fish is actually just really clean
and this is what fresh fish is supposed
to taste like
right I told you that's what that's how
you're supposed to eat fish no you
should try this one okay this is like
their specialty that Mindy this this is
kind of new for them he actually had you
tried a little piece of it yeah it's
like they're ginger poaching so eat the
whole garlic yeah it's like a pickle
Parliament like a harlot
Oh God so this right here apparently
isn't like a whole lot it's like
something that's important to you it's
like their status okay because obviously
they don't have like the atlantic salmon
here but this is actually one of my
favorites
try it asleep it has that delicious like
seaweeds would have hockey labor to it
just like candy now
man
and like salmon has like such a high fat
content if you don't like rock fish
salmon should be like the first one that
you try this is their what this is like
their that's the Hawaiian style so it's
like it's like lima coca which is a
seaweed and salt
it's pretty good has a little kick to it
so they put a little bit of heat mmmm
but their sauces are a little sweet I
like it it is yeah man but if you guys
ever had a time out here to check out
fresh catch and the next time we're here
we'll go into the back kitchen and we'll
show you how it's done
yeah I think what we're going to do and
come back we're out of Hawaii we
actually might go to the fish market but
until then I'm just gonna grab on this
ship right before we go
and in zipline but this one's my
favorite one
[Music]
there's not something I'm too particular
on just because uh I'm scared of heights
I think we're about to go ziplining at
this place called cool little ranches
which is where we're at right now uh
[ __ ] ziplining I don't like Heights but
you know me I'm all about adventure I'm
all about trying things new and I like
how I'm doing this at the heaviest I've
ever been in my life and they have like
roughly about a 280 pound capacity I'm
about 250 doesn't really give me too
much leeway I'm [ __ ] excited I'm
guessing my weights worldly about 260
pounds 280 gotcha
thank you
it's just the biceps dude I'm telling
you man it's all right here up in the
guns you know it's just I'm 261 pounds
zipping Vanessa it's so fast I don't
know my eyes will close the whole time
it was beautiful the inside of my
eyelids all right keep your eyes open
okay strike a pose
zipping David and Vanessa longer this
one's longer yes double that person so
about 400
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I survived clearly as you guys know
I'm basically not scared of anything
anything that I do tackle in life I do
it with a lot of confidence
precision I'm blessed that way but in
all seriousness that [ __ ] was
frightening as [ __ ] for the first four
ones after that you start to get used to
it it gets exciting it wasn't as scary
as my first one because I stopped
screaming after oh hell but yeah but the
ladies here are absolutely amazing and
you know the point of this for me too is
honestly to try to get over my fear of
heights like I don't like being scared
of heights like it's not something I
enjoy it's not like I'm trying to do
this purely for your entertainment I
don't want to be scared of heights but
there's baby steps you know you get
harnessed into this rope that carries
other people and if they didn't die I
shouldn't die so I survived
flowers in the suburb and we bear the
time don't choke when the Sun gets scary
the Tigers off your body
[Music]
I will show
Oh
[Music]
but I don't know when the fire is
bathing the place down
[Music]
so I can walk through the film and take
the old tooth off when the cold
Laur
down to south
I will
[Music]
right
[Music]
I will show
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]